[Music]
Tuesday edition of pro football talk
live NBC sports radio NBCSN hello to our
friends in the UK and in Ireland
enjoying the program on Sky Sports
crisps week three completely and totally
in the books by the way he's Chris Sims
on Mike Florio
I rarely do that I just assumed that
people know maybe they turn their TV on
and they wonder who the hell are these
two idiots and then we proceeded over
the two hours of the morning to confirm
why we are idiots Chris good morning
Harry good morning mr. idiot one how are
you I'm doing fine well I mean we are
idiots
to a certain extent I mean we didn't
think the Rams were playoff material and
here they are three weeks in looking
just like the team they were last year
but there are some things we are right
about we did get more games right than
we got wrong this weekend in the one
game that we got right was the Chicago
Bears beating Washington although for a
while last night it looked like
Washington was gonna make it interesting
but Mitchell true Biscay with three
touchdown passes - Taylor Gabriel who is
listed as 5-7 168 which means he's 5:5
155 and this last one if you're watching
on NBCSN a thing of beauty Mitch Travis
key buys some time in the pocket the
catch in the front corner of the end
zone ruled incomplete by an official
looking right at it this is why they
need to embrace all technologies Chris
to allow someone not just replay review
but someone to be looking at what we see
because we see that as a touchdown
the official standing right there yeah
but quite incomplete but Mike we needed
it slowed down by a hundred times to
figure out it was a touchdown I mean
come on I mean that was you need to see
that in uni these are trained
professionals who need money and I'll
start holding them a little more
accountable okay but that's that's
that's part of the problem yeah it is
part of the ball in his hand yet the
ball did move there's a lot to see there
that was about as bangbang as it gets I
mean that there's human error that's
gonna happen that's why we had replay
they got it right you're a human error I
am alright in there
actually touchdown for Taylor Gabriel
who ended up having a concussion later
in the night and you're talking about
the short week turnaround Vikings game
coming up on Sunday between Taylor
Gabriel's concussion Hakeem Hicks with a
knee injury it's gonna be a tough task
for the Bears to be at full strength for
a tough game at Soldier Field against
the division rival but for last night
look up 28 nothing and Chris we've seen
this time and again teams that have
those big leads very easy for the foot
to slip off the gas pedal and when that
happens next thing you know it's a close
game well yes or potentially it closed
yet potentially a close I mean it should
have been a blowout that's where it went
I mean it should have been you know a 40
to 210 type a game or something along
that you know that range of course
Mitchell troub risky throwing an
interception down there in the red zone
Josh Norman getting it that really is
what saved the Redskins and then gave
them some hope and then the Redskins
have chances there in the fourth quarter
to for themselves to really make it a
one score game and then they have
another turnover which kind of ends the
whole thing in the Eagle I mean the
Bears go down and kick the the kind of
the game clinching field goal but the
Bears defense was the story of the game
holy cow were they unbelievable the
front seven Khalil Mack you know some of
the creative coverages on the back end
by Chuck Pagano they're not missing
picked Vic Fangio they're they're doing
just fine on the defensive side of the
ball and Mike and little identity on
offense finally Mitchell Chu Biscay and
rhythm let's use the short passes as our
run game let's do it that way I mean I
think there were some positives for the
but the Bears to take away from this win
and you may not have noticed it on that
first highlight that we showed of the
sack of Case Keenum by Khalil Mack you
saw who was blocking him didn't you yeah
well didn't you know a tight end tight
end my man look look good on the
whiteboard oh man we blocked him on the
whiteboard we drew the line and he was
four good guys let's go out and practice
don't worry about it that's right it's a
tight end verse one of the Versa
first-ballot hall-of-famer I forgot to
calculate that aspect of it drives me
crazy to see it every week but that
Bears defense kind of asserted itself
last night just say hey we're don't
forget about us we're still one of the
best in football we need to call that
out every time it happens the hope of
shaming every offensive coach into never
putting a tight end on a pass fester
especially not on Khalil Mack yes as
good of an athlete as Vernon Davis is he
ain't blocked and Khalil Mack one-on-one
no he is not and then of course not only
blocking him one-on-one but if we went
back to the clip blocking them on the
full speed run from across the other
side of the field because he's out the
left side and they're trying to do a
play-action pass and you know in the
meeting they drew the line there and
they said okay so if we're gonna ask you
to come across and you block that guy
well that guy is number 52 when that
changes things and how phenomenal was he
last night in the football game
I mean disruptive he's just amazing in
all aspects but really was a the the the
MVP of the football game as far as
getting the Bears out to that 28 nothing
lead yeah Jay Gruden surely wishes it
his brother Jon I've been able to work
it out and keep Khalil Mack in Oakland
so he wouldn't have been playing for
Chicago last night now look the defense
was the story I think for the Bears but
the offense was better than it's been
out of the game Mitchell true Biscay the
quarterback of the Bears was asked
whether or not this was a breakthrough
game for the offense here's what he had
to say
I think we're still growing and evolving
as an offense I don't know if I'd call
it a breakthrough yet we got to keep
getting better keep growing definitely a
room for improvement and definitely the
second half especially on my part so I
think we just stick to the process and
and keep growing and keep learning and
sticking together we're gonna be alright
hey Chris the problem is the running
games still not there David Montgomery
finished was 67 yards he got 25 of them
in one chunk on the drive I made the
game 28 15 to 31 15 very late to wreak
on negative rushing yards that they're
not getting it done running the ball and
when the weather turns and you're
playing games at Soldier Field or you're
playing in January if you make it to the
playoffs you can't rely on Mitch true
Biscay throwing passes to Taylor Gabriel
you got to be able to run the ball at
some point and that's what the Bears
can't do yeah it scares me and you know
again they're in the shotgun every play
Mike you know me when I kind of watch
film of them I go whoo this is not the
most creative run scheme I've seen in
football it's really only about two or
three run plays in general they run and
they just go with it but yes it is it is
a aspect of their offense that certainly
needs to improve and I'm not so sure I
think you watch the game last night
there they kind of told you we're not
sure it's gonna improve I think that's
why you saw all the short passes really
early on in the game one they're
managing Mitchell true Biscay a little
bit too I think they realize they can't
run the ball so they're gonna use a lot
of wide receiver screens and short
passes that way pick plays underneath to
just kind of make up for the lack of
running game and to get mr. drew risky
into a flow of a game early to where
okay he gets a completion just like we
always talk about Mike with a basketball
player few completions ball through the
hoop great and then all of a sudden he
can make a great throw down the field
the Taylor Gabriel for a touchdown
because he's feeling comfortable and
aggressive I at least saw a formula last
night from the Bears offense that made
sense and I think that's the positive
thing the first two weeks I felt like it
was just him going up through plays
going let's do this one let's do that
one let's do this one and I thought
there was some thought behind it last
night the other quarterback Case Keenum
under relentless assault all night long
well Chicago defense five turnovers
three picks and two lost fumbles
including that fourth and one up and
over plunge you
get the first down to keep the drive
going but the ball got knocked out by
Danny Trevathan and that was that
for Washington Keenum was 30 of 43 for
332 yards and a couple of touchdowns but
again five turnovers not good after the
game coach Jay Gruden was asked whether
he would consider making a quarterback
change this week - rookie Dwayne Haskins
as Washington gets ready to take on
rookie Giants quarterback Daniel Jones
here's what Jay Gruden had to say I have
to have some continuity you know I can't
be changing people every five minutes
here so I think case I gotta give case
another an Apple opportunity play with
these new guys and this is first time in
this offense really you know Donald Penn
Eric flowers are first time in this
offense you know Terry trae Quinn only
played two games last I've made this
point before we're not gonna be perfect
but we need to be better and I think we
can get better otherwise if I didn't
think we had a chance to get better than
I would make a change but I feel like
case has the tools to be come a very
efficient quarterback in this offense
and get us some victories here moving
forward hey Chris one of the fascinating
aspects about watching a game on TV and
listening to the broadcast crew is is
trying to hear those messages that are
coming through between the lines of what
people are saying and Booker McFarland
was maybe a little too candid last night
about his thoughts and again they're
with the team for a couple of days
there's a practice there they're meeting
with them yep he got the impression
somehow that Dwayne Haskins playing
isn't gonna happen with Jay Gruden is
the head coach but the Jay Gruden could
be gone at some point this year not that
that's anything earth-shattering right
but to hear it kind of nonchalantly
discussed is almost a given by booger
mcfarland made me think that that maybe
the clock is ticking toward midnight for
Jay Gruden in Washington well I mean you
know the perception is that yeah the
Redskins are dysfunctional and that
everybody looks at the head coach I
think you and I would agree at least I
think you know I don't look at the
Washington Redskins ago Jay Gruden's
really the issue they got to get him out
of here he's the problem I don't know I
mean I don't look at it as like an
overwhelmingly talented roster I never
looked at the team and said oh wow
this team's ready to win and they're
ready to win now and Jay Gruden's mess
this whole thing up no that's not the
case but you know the team is in turmoil
there's a lot of issues they're not that
talented on the offensive side of the
ball of course there's no Trent Williams
and yeah he realizes the reality of the
situation too that if things don't look
good
he is gonna be on the hot seat and I
think he looks at it and goes Dwayne
Haskins raw I know he's got talent I
like him but he probably doesn't think
he's ready to play at this point and
he's kind of mentioning there's a lot of
young other first time people in the
often surround him so I think he's
scared of that formula and he's trying
to give Case Keenum his due but when
Case Keenum s performance is like we saw
last night it's hard not to strike up
the the conversation a little bit
because you know some of those plays are
yeah Bob bad pocket presence move in the
pocket
yeah that's Khalil Mac on the edge step
up have an eye on them you know that
interceptions they weren't necessarily
gonna give you confidence either I mean
two of the three were pretty bad so I
just look at it that way and go you know
another performance like that you're not
really gonna have a choice Jay Gruden
and I think ownership and people like
that and the public pressure is gonna
want Dwayne Haskins in there and
remember what we said before the season
you don't want to go with Dwayne Haskins
because you've got Philadelphia Dallas
and the Bears right out of the gates
yeah it softens up considerably from a
defensive skill standpoint I really want
to give Dwayne Haskins his debut I do it
this week against the Giants yeah yeah
right you're exactly right I mean if
they're just just like the Giants wanted
to start Daniel Jones against the
defense they felt like they could move
the ball against and had a little
familiarity with you know I think that's
the same for the Redskins they got to
look at it and go Dan the Giants can't
cover anybody I mean everybody can throw
the ball on the Giants maybe this is the
game oh they can't pressure the pass or
either damn that is a good game for a
rookie quarterback and I wouldn't be
shot would think those conversations
when they watch the film I think they'll
be underwhelmed by what they saw from
Case Keenum and I think that
conversation will at least start today
whether Dwayne Haskins gets in there and
Chris this is the ultimate no lose
proposition for Washington they could
send Haskins out onto the field on
Sunday at MetLife Stadium against Daniel
Jones and the Giants and ruin his debut
at home right and if they lose
what the hell we're gonna lose anyway
right but you could go out there and say
here's our rookie that went number 15
he's better than your rookie he beats
you're a rookie in his first home game
ever and they're never taken that away
if it happens I I'd go with Haskins in a
heartbeat yeah I get it I get it I you
know it's it's a little bit more I guess
about the feel of the team and where he
thinks the offense is I think I would
probably lean towards Haskins at this
point too and it's not that case
kingdoms played that bad you know the
first two weeks he was he did a lot of
good things he did some good things last
night to bring him back I mean we saw it
but just the simple fact of the matter
is he's not the future and the Redskins
aren't going to the playoffs this year
or the Superbowl or anything like that
and at some point you need you to say
okay this is that is what it is and
let's start the new era
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports